je sais
je t'aime mais je sais pas dans quel
l'année 2007 a été pour toi celle de
toutes les émotions au printemps tu
remporté la grande finale de l'émission
la voix
mais je te battre
[Musique]
à l'otan qui vivait de cette tempête je
trouve le plus aujourd'hui ses débats à
un ami une idole un mentor un produit
temps mais le plus important de dubai un
banc avec un certain recul comment tout
ça mais ça a été une grosse année je
pense pas que j'ai eu le temps encore de
prendre du recul complètement vu la
grosseur de l'année puis j'ai pas
vraiment un véhicule le creux de vague
encore j'ai pas l'impression d'avoir
fait le tour encore d'avoir eu le temps
de 30 véhicules puis de réaliser tout ce
qui s'est passé mais je sais que ça a
été assez intense
[Musique]
lorsque tu es parti en tournée avec ton
parts à l'été 2007
il a insisté pour que vous partager la
même chambre d'hôtel souvenir gardes tu
mets évidemment que aujourd'hui ils sont
encore plus précieux qu'ils l'étaient à
l'époque cet été même si même si c'était
extrêmement précieux mais c'est sûr
qu'on y pense et je comprenne un petit
peu plus pourquoi il demande et supplie
c'est avec beaucoup de bons souvenirs
que je me rappelle ces journées leur pc
c'est juste du bonheur
la première fois que j'interviewe et on
perd 7 en 1998 pour le lancement de son
premier album solo
je sais qu'il me suis tu vois que
j'entends c'est tu vois qui méprise tout
j'ai trouvé très modeste très
professionnelle très humble or quelles
valeurs il te laisse pas mal ces valeurs
là je pense que et teint d'un stade aux
mails depuis autant d'années il faut
comprendre qu'il ya vécu des hauts et
des bas puis en étalant sa famille
proche d'enrôler le véhicule
parallèlement puis ce que ça me
démontrer qu'il faut rien prendre pour
acquis ça prend beaucoup de travail pour
rester dans un milieu comme ça faut
accepter qu'il va avoir des moments plus
difficiles mais j'ai toujours dit que
les up valais les les périodes plus
difficiles ça que j'ai j'assume mais
j'assume donc pris la décision ferme et
bon
si quand eva
[Applaudissements]
n'est ce pas
[Musique]
c'est lui qui en quelque sorte a poussé
à faire ce métier là pas du tout où on
est mais c'est un meilleur ami qui me
citer à chanter dans son groupe
connaissait parce que ses parents
étaient habillés avec mon père puis il y
avait besoin d'un chanteur puis c'est
vraiment un concours de circonstances
jouer au hockey avec lui qui s'est dit
son père et fondateur les jeunes ça doit
être la même chose ça ressemble
tellement et d'orienter pareil comme des
faits chevaliers dans son horloge solde
de pratique puis on a commencé à être
gérés c'est comme ça que j'ai commencé
[Musique]
ce qui m'étonne c'est que tu as 25 ans
mais tu as appris à jouer de la guitare
à 20 ans le ballon tu es tu te montres
ajout l'instant internet youtube
honnêtement j'ai toujours été je suis un
glacis solitaire puis j'ai appris j'ai
appris par moi-même à peu près tout ce
que je sais en ce moment dans la musique
j'ai eu l'aide d'un professeur pour les
cours de chant mais ce qu'il ait
engendré par moi même
[Musique]
est ce que ton père te donner certains
secrets écoute une bonne chanson pop
cycliques comme ceux du devis c'est ce
que des formules de l'écriture de
chansons puisque pour chaque pièce et je
pensais crépeau aucun aucun écrivain
mais c'est un très bon mais là 10 puis
il me oui effectivement appris comment
se laisser aller puis à déposer des
mélodies et seul son désaccord puis ça a
probablement aidé à la composition des
quelques chansons que j'ai sur la sur
mon album
mais ouais c'est sûr que c'est sûr que
c'est très bon professeur
les gens qui nous écoutent connaissent
ton père te respecte un peu moins mais
toi comment tu aimes te décris je pense
que ma joie de vivre transparaît dans la
musique que je fais qui est surtout sur
la scène aussi on est monté un spectacle
très joyeux je voulais que les gens
dansent vu que les gens s'amusent depuis
quelques années un bon moment je
t'emmène là dessus alain lapointe des
bébés s'est montré ouvert ce que soit le
nouveau chanteur des bb
qu'en pensent tout bas
c'est effectivement j'ai entendu ça moi
j'ai mes propres chansons en ce moment
je fais mes propre tournée déjà que je
tresse d'anti fie à mon père je pense
pas que c'est le bon moment pour pour
faire tourner des bébés je dis pas non à
un spectacle hommage aux bébés mais
je me concentre sur le sommet sur mes
propres chansons et m'apporte tournée de
vie bourgeois mercialys mery table
plaisir le plaisir partagé
[Musique]